[Musica]
[Applauso]
io sono un agricoltore le mie sorelle
dio
gestiamo un'azienda agricola abbiamo
sempre fatto anche dell'altro
questo forse ci conferisce un attitudine
a cercare di rompere gli schemi classici
della produzione provare a cambiare
magari abbiamo imparato dai nostri
genitori agricoltori anche loro e
eclettici cerchiamo di avere il famoso
approccio laterale ai problemi ci
riusciamo
vedremo la nostra bisnonna reggina
veramente si chiamava caterina ma tutti
la chiamavano reggina coltivava la terra
nelle campagne e friulane piantava grano
e mais fagioli fra le piante di mais
bruciava l'ulivo per terra per
ingraziarsi la protezione di santa
barbara contro fulmini e tempesta
possiamo sorridere oggi di queste
superstizioni ma devono darci l'idea di
che cosa significasse il terrore di
perdere raccolto significava fame la
nostra bisnonna ida coltivava la terra
nelle pianure venete e vendeva le sue
primizie davanti all'ospedale dopo la
fioritura del mais tagliava la pianta
sopra la spiga per dare quella parte di
verde da mangiare agli animali e la
spiga maturava con quel po di foglie che
le restavano se producevano una
tonnellata e mezzo per ettaro erano
contenti noi oggi ne produciamo 12 14 ma
il record di un agricoltore della
virginia david chiu la con 33,3
tonnellate per ettaro
mica male ma il mais è una pianta dalle
potenzialità incredibili
vorrei condividere con voi alcune
riflessioni sull'agricoltura
l'agricoltura e ciclo è il ritmo delle
stagioni e tempo
e maltempo e pianificazione investimento
il rischio l'agricoltura e provenienza
ma è anche prospettiva è tradizione ma è
anche futuro
allora la domanda che mi pongo oggi è
riusciamo a innovare le nostre
tradizioni riusciamo a prenderli
innovarla e consegnarle migliorate alla
generazione futura
l'agricoltura è ciò che ci dà da
mangiare e quello che deve sfamare un
pianeta sempre più affollato gli
agricoltori non si sono mai sottratti a
questa sfida per esempio quando hanno
sfamato un'europa che usciva devastata
dal secondo conflitto mondiale e lo
hanno fatto innovando ad esempio
introducendo la meccanizzazione passando
da questo a questo ma il tempo del
progresso non è lo stesso per tutti
ovunque
questo è dario oggi sulle ande che
lavora il terreno quelle giampaolo oggi
nella pianura padana che lavora il
terreno oppure abbiamo introdotto la
fertilizzazione per nutrire le piante o
la chimica per proteggerle dalle
malattie delle malerbe e passare da
questo a quello quelle erano le mondine
ore ed ore con le gambe in a mollo
nell'acqua a mondare il riso fra zanzare
e tutto il resto
ma l'innovazione di gran lunga più
importante quella che responsabile del
50 per cento dell'aumento di produzione
che si è avuto negli anni e il
miglioramento genetico
quell'uomo è uno dei più grande e
genetisti italiani uno di quelli che la
genetica agraria la vera mente insegnata
al mondo si chiama nazareno strampelli
ed è anche grazie al suo lavoro se siamo
passati da coltivare frumenti così alti
a quelli bassi e perché vogliamo piante
di taglia ridotta
beh perché quelle alte sprecavano molte
risorse a produrre stelo e foglie
e poca granella per di più cadevano
facilmente si allettavano e quindi la
raccolta era complicata e il prodotto
stando a terra si guastava run di
cattiva qualità
le piante ottenute da strampelli invece
basse sono più produttive quindi possono
essere fertilizzate è il prodotto di
qualità migliore
il tempo ci ha portati da nutrire due
persone per ettaro di terra coltivata
negli anni cinquanta a quattro e mezzo
oggi negli anni cinquanta un'agricoltura
sfamava sei persone oggi 50 grazie a
queste innovazioni abbiamo potuto
produrre di più e abbiamo liberato forza
lavoro che si è spostata
dall'agricoltura all'industria e servizi
sviluppandoli i bambini sono potuti
andare a scuola invece che a lavorare
nei campi
oggi all'agricoltura si chiede di
produrre di più senza aumentare
l'utilizzo di suolo senza aumentare la
persona sull'ambiente prodotto di
qualità migliore a costi accessibili e
soddisfando consumatori sempre più
esigenti cioè l'agricoltura deve essere
sostenibile e deve esserlo per
l'ambiente è evidente
deve esserlo per la società che deve
poter conoscere e condividere i nostri
metodi produttivi e deve essere
economicamente un agricoltore deve poter
vivere dignitosamente del proprio lavoro
se manca una di queste tre gambe
all'intero processo produttivo non sta
in piedi l'agricoltura non è sostenibile
l'ha fatta questa premessa vorrei
cambiare discorso raccontarvi quali
scherzi ci gioca a volte il nostro
cervello albert einstein disse che è più
facile spezzare un atomo che un
pregiudizio il pregiudizio è un muro
nella nostra mente
noi tendiamo a prendere decisioni
basandoci sulle emozioni più che
sull'analisi intellettiva e il nostro
cervello si è evoluto in condizione in
cui la priorità non era il ragionamento
fine da curato ma la decisione rapida
questo salvava la vita
e questo la persona e selettiva ha fatto
evolvere anche nella vita di branco la
priorità era far parte di una tribù
perché questo dava protezione ancora
oggi il nostro cervello cerca di
proteggersi dall ingresso di nuove idee
punta a preservare il nostro senso di
appartenenza di di identità le nuove
idee sono una sfida che accende nel
nostro cervello
la stessa area che elabora le minacce
fisiche
ecco perché tendiamo a reagire con forza
volta con aggressività alle nuove idee
davanti a informazioni che mettano in
discussione le nostre convinzioni
noi tendiamo paradossalmente a reagire
rafforzandole ancora di più si chiamano
vies cognitivi e sono molto forti e ci
caschiamo tutti combattere l'ignoranza
nel senso di mancanza di informazione
con l'informazione e a volte come
gettare benzina sul fuoco guardiamo cosa
sta succedendo con i vaccini io rimango
convinta che sia comunque il metodo
migliore anche perché se conosciamo come
funzionano queste trappole del nostro
pensiero e forse riusciamo più
facilmente a disinnescarle il marketing
le conosce molto bene e le sfrutta lo fa
in modo del tutto legittimo ma noi
ricordiamocelo soprattutto quando si
tratta di prendere decisioni che
influiscono sul futuro del pianeta
vediamo cosa succede nel campo
dell'agroalimentare una piccola
digressione una parrucchiera una volta
per convincermi a fare una tintura mi
disse senza chimica
ora a parte che se fosse stata davvero
senza chimica quella tintura non avrebbe
funzionato ma non sarebbe proprio
esistita perché la chimica è
letteralmente ovunque la chimica evita
la vita e chimica ma noi veniamo
bombardati da anni da una bizzarra
equivalenza naturale uguale buono la
natura è bene l'artificiale è male ma
forse il caso di ricordare che la natura
può anche uccidere
per esempio nel caso della segale
cornuta che causa un intossicazione
mortale al ergotismo o che le scoperte
dell'uomo possono salvare la vita
pensiamo ai diabetici l'insulina che
utilizzano è da anni prodotta da micro
organismi geneticamente modificati per
produrre insulina umana
un tempo si usava quella dei maiali ma
dava effetti collaterali abbastanza
pesanti
la natura con la n rigorosamente
minuscola non è né madre e matrigna
semplicemente si fa i fatti suoi e
infatti i suoi solo che ogni specie
lotta per sopravvivere
ecco perché naturale può anche uccidere
ecco perché artificiale nel senso di
manipolato da l'uomo può salvare la vita
niente di ciò che coltiviamo e naturale
ma non lo è da quando l'uomo è diventato
agricoltore ha cominciato a cambiare le
piante a selezionarle a migliorarle per
i propri scopi confondere natura
agricoltura è
una scorciatoia che apparentemente
semplifica i nostri processi decisionali
ma in realtà è una strada chiusa una
trappola
la natura una risorsa preziosa noi
dobbiamo tutelarla ne va della nostra
sopravvivenza
ma questo non è compito dell'agricoltura
l'agricoltura non è naturale è un
processo artificiale confondere natura
agricoltura ci porta al paradosso per
eccellenza che è quello di rifiutare
l'innovazione anche quando riduce
l'impatto ambientale ad esempio più
eclatante è quello del mais bt si tratta
di un mais geneticamente modificato per
proteggersi da solo dagli attacchi di un
insetto la piralide ma in italia non è
permesso di coltivarlo quindi noi per
proteggere il nostro mais evitare che
venga attaccato la piralide che diventi
una schifezza invendibile tossico per le
persone e gli animali che dovessero
nutrirsene siamo costretti a trattare a
tappeto i nostri campi di mais con
insetticida proviamo a fare un altra
riflessione davanti alla malattia noi
chiediamo la medicina
l'ultimo ritrovato oppure alla
tecnologia informatica chiediamo sempre
maggior rapidità e tutto questo lo
pretendiamo
ma contemporaneamente ci disorienta il
tempo del progresso è rapido a volte
troppo perché la società si adegui senza
disagio e allora cerchiamo un punto di
riferimento che ci rassicuri ci dia
certezze
il cibo è ancora perfetta quando si
tratta del cibo di mettere in bocca e
frutti del campo qualcosa scatta dentro
di noi vogliamo tutti i costi essere
rassicurati che sia tradizionale che sia
come una volta che sia il cibo della
nonna illudendoci di
preservare un passato che credeteci
viene dipinto come molto più roseo di
quanto in realtà non fosse noi
impediamo l'agricoltura di innovare in
definitiva condanniamo a morte le nostre
tradizioni
eppure se andassimo a vedere come furono
accolti alla loro introduzione alcuni
degli alimenti che oggi consideriamo
tipici della nostra gastronomia
resteremmo stupiti la melanzana per
esempio fu introdotta in italia nel
medioevo dagli arabi
secondo alcune fonti sono me deriva da
mela insana oppure le patate i pomodori
come saprete sono originari del
sudamerica per molto tempo in europa
furono considerati velenosi ma un
esempio molto interessante quello della
pastorizzazione del latte nella metà
dell'ottocento nelle città americane la
morte il taf until aveva raggiunto il 50
per cento molto anche a causa
dell'abitudine a consumare latte crudo
quando fu introdotto l'obbligo la
pastorizzazione del latte
la gente è scesa in strada ci furono
violente sommosse non ne volevano sapere
di questa novità pensavano fosse un
imbroglio escogitato dall'industria per
riuscire a smerciare prodotto avariato
guardate che i meccanismi mentali sono
sempre gli stessi ancora oggi
eppure la monte l'età infantile crollò
di due terzi
proviamo allora a smontare un piatto
tipico della nostra tradizione la pasta
al pomodoro il grano per fare la pasta
deriva dalla fusione totale dei genomi
di due diverse piante selvatiche
avvenuta in natura in modo del tutto
casuale migliaia di anni fa altro che gm
dove si sposta un gene quei geni si sono
spostati tutti e senza l'intervento
dell'uomo
forse potremmo dire che il grano è un
ogm naturale e il pomodoro per fare il
sugo abbiamo visto viene dal sud america
e se vogliamo aggiungere un po di
basilico molto bene ma che si sappia e
originario dell'india
allora la conclusione di questa
deliziosa pasta asciutta al pomodoro e
basilico è che forse noi italiani siamo
davvero bravi innovare a prendere i
frutti del mondo ea metterli insieme
riusciamo a innovare le nostre
tradizioni perché siamo giunti al punto
che se vogliamo salvarle
dobbiamo davvero applicare loro una
bella dose di sana innovazione
ma cosa significa innovazione in
agricoltura perché ci serve ci serve per
cambiare perché i nostri processi
produttivi nel tempo e diventano
obsoleti costosi inadeguate alle sfide
del pianeta dobbiamo innovare perché i
patogeni nel tempo cambiano
e a noi servono nuovi metodi per
difendere le nostre colture senza
aumentare la pressione sull'ambiente
dobbiamo innovare perché il clima sta
cambiando bisogna adattare le piante
all'ambiente non viceversa
ci servono piante che tollerano la
salinità piante che tollerano la carenza
idrica in caso di siccità o viceversa
piante che tollerino la sommersione
in caso di alluvioni il clima e
l'ambiente stanno cambiando e noi non
possiamo farci cogliere impreparati
anche perché abbiamo tutte le competenze
per farlo
dobbiamo innovare perché i mercati la
società stessa nel tempo cambiano ea noi
serve la siccità per adeguarci alle loro
esigenze
poteva il made in italy made in italy è
un grande successo e richiestissima in
tutto il mondo le esportazioni
dell'industria alimentare continuano a
crescere
fa piacere ma avete notato detto
industria alimentare non agroalimentare
perché noi soddisfiamo solo metà del
nostro fabbisogno di cereali alimentari
e zootecnici e solo un terzo del nostro
fabbisogno di proteine vegetali il resto
lo importiamo ciò significa che prodotti
necessari a produrre mangimi che diamo
agli animali che ci forniranno il made
in italy prosciutti formaggi e salumi
eccetera sono in buona parte importati e
spesso sono geneticamente modificati
sono del tutto sicuri sia ben chiaro ma
sia ben chiaro anche l'assurdo paradosso
in cui ci siamo ficcati cioè noi non
impediamo noi non consentiamo i nostri
agricoltori di coltivare ciò che poi
importiamo in massa per produrre il made
in italy ma è un suicidio economico non
senso scientifico è un pasticcio
giuridico è un imbroglio
allora se vogliamo salvare la
reputazione del made in italy
dell'agroalimentare italiano
abbiamo bisogno di un'agricoltura
efficiente e performante innovativa
ecco perché non c'è alcuna
contraddizione fra prodotto tradizionale
e innovazione
innovazione progresso sono la chiave
verso un'agricoltura sostenibile e
questo obiettivo si raggiunge più in
fretta se l'agricoltore ricercatori
lavorano insieme ognuno con le proprie
competenze
lasciamo ricercatori liberi di fare il
loro mestiere
lasciamo le aziende libere di scegliere
gli strumenti necessari a stare sul
mercato
un'azienda economicamente vitale è
un'azienda in grado di aprire le proprie
porte alla società e di mostrare con
orgoglio come lavora la tutela
dell'ambiente è una priorità anche per
noi agricoltori noi in quell'ambiente ci
lavoriamo spesso ci viviamo
allora forse dovremmo riflettere sul
fatto che quello che noi oggi chiamiamo
tradizione i nostri nonni chiamavano
innovazione perché per me agricoltori e
tradizione innovare grazie